listen history was made this weekend
when a Halifax man decided to take on
quite the feet and eat Riley Mary
challenged himself to eat five pounds of
potato salad and he planned on doing so
at the Holy Cross Cemetery at the grave
site of former prime minister Sir John
Sparrow Thompson and of course we are
all asking why I know I am so he's here
the man the myth the legend that you're
seeing in those photos right now he is
in the global Newsroom Riley AKA potato
salad guy is here hello sir hi good
morning how's it going today listen I
need to ask you that question how are
you feeling uh today is a tenfold better
than I was the last couple of days but
overall it's been a really good weekend
oh my gosh okay so you as we saw in some
of those photos you attempted the
challenge H how first of all h no I
don't even know where to start with
these questions why let's go with why uh
plain and simple uh I buy potato salad
on the regular uh I didn't end up
getting into eating this uh I'm not
really a potato salad fan by any measure
uh but I realized it was going to expire
uh I didn't have time to reasonably eat
it so uh I looked at it saw the expiry
date and said that's a challenge I can
do it and so okay so you posted online
made just kind of a funny video made the
posters and this blew up yeah it was uh
I probably spent about 45 minutes uh I
made a Snapchat uh I made a couple
posters uh I didn't think anything of it
uh kind of went to bed when I woke up
the next morning people were like is
this real uh so I've committed to the
bit and I'm sitting here today so and
you're sitting here today just a couple
pounds heavier how far into that 5B tub
did you officially get officially uh I
know online the consensus is 3.5 it was
3.8 we we made it a little bit further
there I and those count yeah that couple
extra bites okay so obviously there was
a crowd here including police why were
police there you didn't actually get
into this uh Cemetery correct no no they
um so from my understanding there's a uh
Catholic Council of Nova Scotia
apparently they own the cemetery so um I
won't I won't lie uh if I had a family
member who was buried next to the Prime
Minister I probably wouldn't want a guy
puking potato salad on him uh so I can
see why they closed it uh so the police
were just there for precautionary
measures uh they weren't a problem it
was it was a good time all together and
uh they made the pictures look better so
they did make the pictures look better
okay so why the former prime minister
though like what's the connection there
with Benny see I don't want to say that
I don't fully trust the royal family but
there are some suspicious things going
on over there um if you guys don't know
about it he died in the Windsor Castle
right after being kned by the queen
herself uh and some people say it was a
heart attack uh other people are
investigating have questions okay okay
all right we'll leave that we'll leave
that side of the story for the time
being um why why do you think that
everybody just jumped on board with this
and loved it uh honestly it's uh we're
kind of in a bit of a pressure cooker
right now things in the world are not
they're not great um this is just
something that I never intended to have
a gathering but if people want to gather
around something positive uh bring the
whole city together uh if I'm going to
be potato salad guy and that's what's
going to happen so be it that that's
what happens gosh okay we need to talk
about this this is an incredible
painting an oil canvas done by an artist
here in Halifax Shannon Dawn there might
be a little bit of a charity aspect you
guys have partnered up potentially yeah
so uh we're very very very very early
stages uh nothing's concrete yet but uh
it seems like a lot of people at least
general interest in uh maybe buying some
prints uh the actual oil campus itself
will probably be put up for auction uh
again neither of us want any funds from
this this was completely created out of
uh humor so uh out of Good Humor we're
going to try to help some people out
here and if uh you guys are interested
in some prints there of the the oil
painting uh we'll try to get them on
some t-shirts or whatever amazing Kate
you you told Paul and I during the
commercial before we came live here that
you did some training for this how does
one train to eat five l pounds of potato
salad well as a uh as a man on a budget
with absolutely no time to get ready for
this uh it involved a lot of Costco hot
dogs and a lot of two lers of pop so uh
for the most part two Costco hot dogs a
day and about uh 2 lers of lime big
eight pop okay there you go that's how
you train for a marathon of this H
caliber here um what's next are you
we've we've got some we've got some of
the good stuff here will you ever take a
bite of this ever again
uh there's a good chance uh I can't lose
to a tub of potato salad uh I can't let
myself go down like that so uh I have no
set date yet but there will be round two
uh potato salad man is not going to lose
to the potato salad just simply not
going to you heard it here first we will
have more when it's breaking news when
the date is announced rley this has been
this has been a lot of fun did you have
any idea that this is what would come
from you not at all I'm uh I mean this
is definitely something straight out of
my type of Playbook but uh no this kind
of snowballed and turned into an
avalanche and uh I can't appreciate it
more than I am right now this is great
amazing well listen we appreciate your
time this morning very excited to see
you maybe dig into uh another couple
pounds of this not today though we won't
put you through that we'll let you keep
training for maybe a couple months
before thank you thank you we'll uh see
you guys in the new year and uh I I
won't lose next time we promise that
Riley Mary right here aka the potato
salad
guy